an effort to restore calm Israel's prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu has said he
will pause controversial changes to the
country's Judicial System later today
though thousands of Israelis are still
expected to Rally across the country as
those proposals remain on the table MTS
Tire reports now from Jerusalem and how
Israel's population remains deeply
divided over their hopes for their
future
Israel's far right is mobilizing those
who support overhauling the Judiciary
are now taking to the streets in even
bigger numbers the Supreme Court has
been in place for 75 years why change it
the majority where the majority that
wants reform
[Music]
but those opposed are still protesting
despite the reforms being put on hold
this week saying they're defending
democracy for all if passed the judicial
overhaul would allow members of
parliament to select judges and overrule
court rulings with a simple majority
removing one of the few checks on
Government powers warned these
protesters but for historian rhonicella
Israel's democracy has already
compromised since its formation and
after more than half a century of
occupying Palestinian territory what
you're saying is Jewish Israelis have
been sleepwalking into this by ignoring
the Palestinian situation exactly
exactly and now we are experiencing
exactly what the Palestinian experience
since 48 and then 667 in the occupied
territory with the apartheid with Varian
start time and now when it's knock on
our door we just woke up
a nearly 2 million Palestinians with
Israeli citizenship have largely sat out
the anti-judicial overhaul
demonstrations with Palestinian
activists saying their rights have been
attacked for years and never have there
been Mass demonstrations against the
injustices they face at the hands of the
government and the courts menir naseba
is a Palestinian law professor why have
so many Palestinian citizens of Israel's
Not Taken part in these protests they
find themselves outside the picture of
the Israeli National dreams and National
planning and therefore they haven't been
participating and they don't see
themselves part of of the whole of the
whole project
a project that now hangs into balance
for all sides for CBS Saturday morning
in Fiesta Jerusalem